de l'effervescence dans l'air comme au
sol et la jta triste et elle ses cordes
vocales vibre au rythme de deux genres a
priori très éloignées l'opéra et
l'europe pour un voyage dont seul second
connaît la destination
qui repousse les limites du réel en fait
donc en fait rejoindre un monde
d'énergie en fait de connexion à la
terre au ciel à la lumière à tour les
spectateurs ont embarqué avec étonnement
et plus c'est de la qualité c'est super
ça l'univers bien à part beaucoup aimé
la musique et ça change de voie sans
issue à tours pour cette fête de la
musique
les mélanges originaux occupe le devant
de la scène comme avec ce groupe entre
jazz électro et métal dont les t4 est
approximative c'est aussi au public de
faire sa propre idée imaginée son propre
univers et voilà on n'a pas envie d'être
super concret sur ce point là donc voilà
on a nos idées qui sont pas toutes
exactement les mêmes d'ailleurs mais on
a un espèce de fil conducteur qui en
gros on joue dans un monde qui est pas
ce monde là la plupart des spectateurs
ont ainsi découvert un nouvel univers
etc se ment jamais vu une qualité comme
ça en province
cette 34e édition de la fête de la
musique aura permis à certains de
s'ouvrir vers des groupes alternatifs et
de se faire de nouvelles idoles
oh